George: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Domino's in Japan and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Japan, Domino's pizzas
come in three sizes.
Our Domino's pizza comes in four sizes.
George: So, this one is medium,
which is cut into 8 slices.
Joe: Over here on this
end, you got the small.
That's 10-inch pizza.
And here's regular, which is
also cut into eight slices.
Joe: Next up is our medium.
That's a 12-inch pizza.
And this one is large.
This one is cut into 12 slices.
Joe: Then we move to our large, 14 inches.
And finally, the extra
large, which is 16 inches.
Look at all that grease.
A Domino's large plain pizza
has a 33-centimeters diameter
or an 855.3-square-centimeters area
and costs 2,000 yen.
So breaking that down,
our pizza is 2.33 yen per square inch,
or about 2 cents.
Now take our large.
This is a 14-inch pizza,
also a 35.56-centimeter pizza.
And it has a surface area
of 993.1 square centimeters.
That's 1.4 cents per square inch,
or 1.62 Japanese yen.
But what gives you the
most food for your money?
So, here's a large plain
slice with a pan crust.
And here's another with hand-tossed crust.
Let's weigh both right
now and see which is more.
So, first let's weigh pan crust.
51 grams.
And hand-tossed crust.
It weighs 49 grams.
And we will do the same.
I want to note that right now in America,
you can only get the pan
Domino's in the medium size.
Same exact experiment, only
I'm doing two medium pizzas.
Medium pan slice, medium
hand-tossed slice.
So, this is the hand-tossed slice,
and it weighs
a smidge over 75.
We'll go 76.
The pan.
That goes in there too.
110 grams.
Making the difference this amount.
I'm not doing math.
In Japan, we have seven
different crust options.
No. 1, we have pan.
And No. 2 we have hand-tossed.
And No. 3, we have ultra-crispy.
Ooh.
It's like a cracker.
No. 4, we have cheese burst,
where a string cheese is placed
around the edge of the crust
and sprinkled with consommé
Parmesan seasoning.
Ooh.
No. 5, we have the cheese 'n' roll.
It's got mozzarella cheese in the crust.
And No. 6, we have mille-filet.
Or mill-foy.
Mille-fail.
In Japanese we say mi-ru fi-yu.
So this one is mi-ru-fi-yu pizza,
which has two layers of crust
with Camembert mixed cheese in between.
Mille-fail.
Mille-fee-yuh.
French people, please
correct my pronunciation.
No. 7, the last one we have,
the triple mille-feuille.
It's got three layers of
crust with cheese in between.
Wow.
In the US, we have only
five crust options.
I realize there's four
pizzas in front of me.
Let me explain.
One crust option you can get here,
and it's a small only,
is the gluten-free crust.
I don't know how bread is gluten-free,
but we figured it out.
Ta-da.
We also have the hand-tossed,
which is more of a standard pillowy,
I mean, right, this is
like standard dough,
this is what we think a pizza looks like.
This is the pan.
Look how thick that is, man.
That's, like, triple the dough thickness.
Good on you for the pan.
Now, you can get this in the medium only.
We also have a crunchy thin crust.
And we have so many
pizzas here, to be honest,
I don't know which one it is.
So when it just comes up in
the video, I'll show it off.
But imagine a crunchy thin pizza.
Oddly enough, we also
have something called
the Brooklyn-style pizza.
This is reserved for large
and extra-large pizzas only.
And this is a Brooklyn-style
right here, extra large.
Obviously it isn't crispy,
because it's sagging.
This is really thin.
Here's everything you can
get at the Japanese Domino's
that you cannot get in the US.
Here's everything you
can get at a US Domino's
you cannot get in Japan.
Everyone, look at this.
This is a limited-time-offer pizza.
It's called the Best 34.
Look at this lid.
It's disgusting!
Don't look at me! Don't look at me!
So, this one has all 34 Domino's toppings,
like teriyaki chicken, mayo,
spinach, tomato, shrimp.
This is huge.
It's like my baby.
[sings lullaby]
The New Yorker-style pizza is similar
to the Brooklyn XL option
you can get in America.
But only in Japan you can
get the Quattro New Yorker.
It's a 16-inch pizza with
each New Yorker topping style
covering a quarter of the pizza.
So one quarter is pepperoni,
and one is cheese,
and one is pepperoni and sausage,
and one is ham and mushroom.
So, here we have Nippon favorites series.
Nippon, or Nihon, means Japan in Japanese.
So these pizzas feature
Japanese ingredients.
This one charcoal-grilled
teriyaki chicken.
It's got teriyaki chicken, teriyaki sauce,
spinach, mayonnaise, and corn.
Next we have Hokkaido three cheeses.
So, Hokkaido is the northern
island prefecture in Japan,
and it's famous for its cheese.
It's got Hokkaido Gouda cheese,
Hokkaido cheddar cheese,
and Hokkaido Camembert
and sliced asparagus.
We have spicy mayo and mochi.
It's got mochi rice cake and corn,
pork sausage and sliced asparagus,
and Korean seaweed flakes.
And last one, we've got
charcoal-grilled beef
and spinach and mushrooms.
Mm!
Oh!
Umai!
This beef is so tender,
and it's got so much,
like, charcoal flavor,
which makes this amazing.
I love this.
So many exclusive pizzas
here at the US Domino's.
I don't know where to begin,
so I'll just start with
this one that I'm holding.
This is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
I don't know what makes it
California-in-y or Cali-y,
but it definitely has
chicken, and bacon, and ranch,
and it's big.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Chicken taco pizza.
Oh, yeah.
Got taco spices to it.
Good job on this one.
Next one, the cheeseburger pizza.
Um ...
Yeah. Oh, my God.
I'm going to say something crazy.
This tastes exactly like
a McDonald's cheeseburger.
Even has the oniony
and the ketchupy taste.
Wow.
That is a surprise.
I thought this one was going to be bad,
but it's actually pretty good.
The extravaganZZa.
This has pepperoni, sausage, ham,
mushrooms, black olives, green peppers.
This is the meatZZa,
which I'm assuming is just a lot of meat.
I'm seeing sausage, I'm seeing pepperoni,
and maybe hamburger.
Yeah, I'll put this in the good pile.
I f--- with this one.
Philly cheesesteak.
Oh, no.
In some weird way, I'm
blaming you for this.
Since you handed this to
me, this is your fault.
Look at this nightmare.
Meat somewhere on here.
I'm also seeing green peppers.
Oh. Look, look, it's like,
look at that, it's,
like, stuck to the box.
No.
Buffalo chicken.
OK, OK.
This is more my speed.
Chicken.
No, not tomato sauce, like a white sauce.
Good call.
Mm!
This isn't Buffalo enough.
The capital of the great state of New York
needs to be better
represented in this pizza.
The capital of New York
is Buffalo, correct?
No?
We got the Memphis barbecue chicken.
Love Memphis.
Love barbecue.
Love chicken.
Yeah.
The key thing here is the barbecue sauce.
I don't know what is in it,
but, man, that's really good.
Memphis,
capital of the great state of Tennessee.
Everyone, here is the
ultra cheese New Yorker.
It's got 1 kilogram of cheese,
or 2.2 pounds.
OMG.
Ooh!
Look how thick this cheese is!
Go!
Go home.
It weighs 180 grams,
180 times eight equals
1,440 grams in total.
So, here are other
Japanese specialty pizzas.
So, here we have quattro meat max.
So it's got charcoal-grilled
teriyaki chicken
and charcoal-grilled beef
and giga meat and Goryeo galbi.
It's Korean-style beef pizza.
And next we have seafood special.
This part and this part
is shrimp mayonnaise.
So this part, it's got shrimp, octopus,
mussels, littleneck clams,
Mactra clams, green peppers,
and cherry tomatoes.
Next we've got garlic master.
Looks so spicy.
Garlic and pork sausage and pancetta.
And this part has got jalapeño, obviously.
It's picante.
Pepperoni and Italian sausage and onions.
And look at this huge thing.
Mayo jaga.
So, jaga, or jagaimo,
means potato in Japanese.
It's got potato and pork sausage
and a lot of mayo.
Joe: Our US Domino's has
sandwiches and pasta.
I was not a fan of the
Philly cheesesteak pizza,
but let's see what the Philly
cheesesteak tastes like
in its native form of sandwich.
Better than the pizza.
Also at the US Domino's,
you can get a Buffalo chicken sandwich,
a chicken habanero sandwich,
the Mediterranean veggie,
no, thanks,
a chicken bacon ranch,
an Italian sandwich,
and, of course, the chicken Parm sandwich.
Our Domino's has four
pastas to choose from.
I only got two, the chicken Alfredo
and the Italian sausage marinara.
You can also get a chicken
carbonara and a pasta primavera.
I've just been informed
I have to eat this.
Strong flavor on this.
I would skip the pasta
at Domino's, personally.
This thing is, like, baked on.
See how baked this is?
Like, come on.
I feel like chef Ramsay here.
Just, "Oh, come on. Oh,
this baked on here!"
In the US, we have a few chicken options
you can't get in Japan.
Yes, Japan has wings,
but they don't have these flavors.
Visually, I can see why.
First flavor we got here
is the garlic Parmesan.
Hey, Domino's, what are you doing?
Next one, we got,
I'm assuming this is the honey barbecue.
These drizzles! What are you
guys doing drizzling, man?
Just toss it!
Toss it in the sauce!
Nobody wants a drizzle.
Oh, wait a second.
This is the sweet mango habanero.
I wasn't expecting that heat.
Oh, man.
Very good.
These are --
why did you do this?
Why did you do this?
Toss it in the sauce.
Why'd you just squirt it on
here, like, as an afterthought?
Honey barbecue.
Right? Is this not nuts?
This is nuts, right, that
they did it like this.
I like the sauce.
So, Domino's also does their
wings in boneless flavors.
They have obviously those three,
and you can also get these two other ones.
And I see we have the
crispy bacon and tomato,
and this one must be the
spicy jalapeño pineapple.
Whoa, what?
Hell yeah.
All right.
Get that B-roll fast.
There it goes!
I know.
Your audible gasps are warranted.
I don't know what this --
what am I supposed to do with this?
Ooh, this one I'm looking
forward to, Yuelei.
We got the food less than an hour ago.
I don't think an hour is
unrealistic for food to sit.
I think you guys gotta
put some more chemicals
in your cheese to keep it goopier longer.
Ooh, I got some pineapple,
and I got some jalapeño,
and I got some chicken.
Let's check it out.
Yeah.
Overall, everything
here tastes pretty good.
Presentation, you gotta work on that.
In Japan, we don't have boneless wings,
but we have Japanese fried chicken,
which is called karaage.
It kind of looks like
American boneless wings.
Ah.
I love karaage.
And also we have chicken nuggets.
Both come in four, eight, and 12 pieces.
Our Domino's has breads
and oven-baked dips.
Let's review the breads first.
Shall we?
Over here,
we have Parmesan bread twists
and garlic bread twists.
I know that because of their
totally twisted shapes.
They also have Parmesan bread bites
that were currently unavailable.
Whoa.
Uh-oh.
These are very good.
To Parmesan we go.
Not as good.
But still pretty good.
I mean, it's bread and
cheese and oil, right?
US Domino's also has something
called stuffed cheesy bread.
You can get your stuffed
cheesy bread with either
spinach and feta or bacon and jalapeños.
Take a wild guess which one I chose.
[beep] Just ripping this
whole [beep] thing apart.
Oh, God!
This thing is especially greasy.
For whatever reason,
Domino's didn't stop there.
Domino's has something called dips.
[sighs]
What it appears to be
is a giant dish of melted cheese.
And you can get it in cheesy
marinara or five cheese.
What are we doing, Domino's?
[laughs]
What is this?
Come on, guys.
So, this is the marinara
one, I'm assuming.
A pizza without the bread, right?
These dips are literally
zapping my will to live.
Please don't ever get ...
It's a whole bowl of cheese, Yuelei!
Why would -- oh, look
at the oil in this too!
Everyone in here just gagged.
Can I even dip it?
Oh, whoa.
I don't know what of the
five cheeses is in here,
like, which five.
Why am I eating this?!
Ugh!
So, here are our Japanese
exclusive side-menu items.
Let's start with this one.
We've got oven-baked potato wedges.
This one is plain.
Consommé.
Chili garlic.
And this one is butter.
And next we have cheese sticks.
Shrimp popcorn.
It comes with this tartar sauce.
Here we have choregi salad.
We've got Korean-style seaweed flakes
and choregi dressing.
So, choregi is, like,
Korean-style sesame-oil dressing.
And fresh salad in the package.
So, here we have corn potage.
Clam chowder.
Minestrone.
Black chili.
You've seen these before.
It is the Domino's
marbled cookie brownies.
♪ Liquid sugar ♪
Oh, yeah.
You can also get these
cinnamon bread twists.
Lastly, another dip.
I swear to God, if there's cheese in this,
I'm walking out of here
and I'm never coming back.
Baked apple dips.
And I'm assuming you dip these into this.
I'm not gonna.
So, here are our other desserts.
We have mini pancakes,
heart-shaped fondant chocolate,
and here we have egg custard tart.
I have never tried this one before.
Itadakimasu.
Mm.
Mm!
This is so good.
So flaky.
Mm.
This one is apple pie.
And next we have custard pie.
Lastly, of the sodas
you can get in the US,
can't get in Japan,
get yourself Fanta orange and Sprite.
We have Coke Zero.
It's supposed to be Zero,
but they gave us just normal Coke.
Next, we have ginger ale.
Canada Dry.
Canada is an amazing country, eh?
Qoo orange juice.
And here is Sokenbicha.
It's Japanese blended tea.
And last one, we've got Georgia Japan
Craftsman café latte.
Georgia Japan.
Sounds like George Japan.
I'd like to be sponsored by you.
Let me try this.
It's got a lot of milk and sugar in it.
I gotta be honest.
It's not my taste.
Take two.
I really love this.
Please give me a sponsorship.
A Japan large hand-tossed pizza
is 130 calories per slice,
or 1,560 calories for the full pizza.
In the US, a large hand-tossed
pizza slice is 280 calories,
which makes the entire
pizza 2,240 calories.
A large big-pepperoni hand-tossed slice
is 335 calories per slice,
or 4,020 calories for the entire pizza.
Our large pepperoni is
370 calories per slice,
which makes the entire pie 2,960 calories.
Japan's most calorific pizza is
the ultra cheese New Yorker size.
One slice is 478 calories.
That's 3,827 for the full pizza.
Ah.
Our US Domino's pizza
with the most calories
is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
This is an XL of said pizza.
One slice is 560 calories,
and that makes the full
pie 3,360 calories.
Our large plain pizza
has 1,620 calories total.
Our large cheese is 2,240 calories.
That's a 38.2% increase.
Our large big pepperoni is 2,680 calories,
over 34% of your daily
recommended calorie intake.
333% of your daily sodium.
Ah!
Too many tasty calories!
Ours is 2,960 calories,
48% over your daily recommended amount,
but somehow ours has less sodium,
only 299% of your daily sodium.
In October of last year,
a study found detectable
amounts of phthalate,
a plastic softener, in common menu items
from large fast-food
chains, including Domino's.
The study analyzed 64 food samples
from several popular fast-food chains
and found phthalates DnBP and DEHP
in a majority of the items.
USA Today reported that,
"Food containing meat,
such as chicken burritos
and cheeseburgers,
had higher levels of
the chemicals studied,
while cheese pizza had the lowest levels."
OK, so that's good news
for Domino's, I guess.
The study goes on to say
that "food handling gloves
contain replacement plasticizers,
which may be [a] source
of food contamination."
Sounds to me like an easy fix.
Just prepare the food without gloves.
Japan has a ban on DEHP
in food-handling gloves.
Good-er news, if you're
a fan of "Food Wars"
and saw the US versus UK Domino's episode,
we highlighted BHA and
BHT in the US pepperoni.
Well, on the stewardship
page on Domino's website,
they have stated, ahem,
"We have eliminated a long list
of ingredients from all
of our core products
including BHA and BHT and PHOs,
as well as trans-fat from
core pizza products,"
which is fantastic news.
I clearly was going to eat it anyway,
but thank you regardless.
[cricket chirping]
Our cricket is back.
Nothing can stop the mating call
of the North American, or
the West Coast cricket.
OK, here we go. [clears throat]